nature à faire bonne ou mauvaise idée
mathieu dans touche pas à mon poste
alors là qu'est ce que voulait rester
avec nous est ce qu on voulait vous
mettre la balle est écouté et revenir
après un jeu marais sera à laval
accueillera les imac jeunes à revenir
sur lui allez-y mathieu allez vous savez
quoi pour faire ce vol ou mauvaise idée
on accueille une chroniqueuse voix qui
nous rejoint comme ça elle va rentrer
tout de suite en selle le fera avec nous
c'est erika moulet convient de voir dans
dans le magnéto voilà qui nous rejoint
on peut l'applaudir eric est arrivé
abba
scala année et c'est moi qui tu croyais
je croyais qu allah l'école al ahram un
trou cela non mais sérieux mais qu'il ya
des stylos tous des préservatifs alors
scellé stimorol mais ça ce match aussi
aller comment ça va erika alors ça y est
on est dans le
c'était vous savez pas danser on va dans
cette émission des impressions j'ai eu
et j'ai enchaîné samedi bien franchement
s'il ya quelqu'un un danseur de alors
vous avez tous d'anciens mais oui je
sais je sais que bertrand chabot à vous
plais bien c'est ce qu'on m'a dit non
bertrand c'est mon c'est quelqu'un qui
me touche que j'apprécie beaucoup de
tort à dans les loges pas dans les
voiles à bercy vous allez faire le
grenoble mauvaise idée matthieu
delormeau dans tpm pc partie ces
deuxièmes dos douloureux alors mathieu
donc mathieu est ce que c'est une bonne
ou une mauvaise idée dans touche pas à
mon poste il va nous regarder il va voir
tout ce que vous dites bien sûr alors il
ya des bonnes idées mauvaise idée angela
bonne idée mauvaise idée pour gilles
verdez mauvaise idée pour sur l'udc
attention on y va boni alors vous savez
les oreilles sinon elle fait toujours un
truc là l'autre qui dit quand même j'ai
toujours un truc qui me démangent
qu'est-ce qui se passe je ne sais pas
brusquement sam à gratter a hélas quand
vous avez les six noms dont l'émission
sera bonne ou mauvaise idée alors
mathieu qui était sur nrj 12
alors moi il le sait très bien et
quelques années je pouvais pas
l'encadrer comme moi je fais partie des
gens qui mettent des petites marbre à
charge ou à décharge je l'écouté je
pourrais que c'est un garçon intelligent
maintenant je le mets ya déjà un an
disait que c'était dommage qu'on lui
faisait faire là bas donc c'est normal
que ça content qu'il soit là
julien bonne idée pour une agence m6 on
doit chacun de donner un avis sur la
télé en tant que entre guillemets
spécialistes c'est un spécialiste de la
téléréalité
moi je n'avais jamais produit je peux
difficilement parler je peux vous parler
de jeux faut pas les pleins de choses
que je pense qu'il aura des trucs à dire
sur la télé réalité particulièrement
chaos bonne idée
je pense que c'est une stratégie
gagnante tout ce qu'il a fait il s'en
est quand même pris plein la tête
il ya certaines personnes qui ont pensé
qu'il était un peu mort donc je pense
que c'était ce qui pouvait lui arriver
de mieux d'arriver dans cette équipe
en revanche moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
voir s'il va cracher dans la soupe de la
télé réalité et de toutes ces chaînes
comme nrj12 et caetera et se refaire un
nouveau personnage ou s'il va rester
fidèle à ce qu'il fait depuis des années
erika mauvaise idée vous voulez bien
venir mais pas lui pas
il y avait la place pour tout le monde
mais mathieu on n'a pas ces mauvaises
années ensemble moi j'étais energy avec
lui sa place en tant que j'ai pris avec
mon nom soit pas été quelqu'un de sympa
avec moi c'est vraiment on en a discuté
la gelée vu tout à l'heure je pense que
les vacances ont fait du bien je pense
cependant on est sur un bon terrain
mais c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas été top
ben sur son sur son plateau l'accueil
n'a pas été terrible et c'est pas
quelqu'un qui disait bonjour facilement
mais je commençais est il qu'à effet une
très bonne route à faire vraiment mal
dit la vérité
moi j'aime les gens comme des sudistes
on a fait le clip en dix ans on a rigolé
mais n'ont pas de toit n'attaque pas du
tout du maure de touraine mais laissez
moi non je parle aussi de 2h15 la télé
ça se ressent aussi donc je parle
vraiment aussi de l'homme qu'il est il
n'a pas été cool avec moi et c'est vrai
que ça s'est ressenti parce que même les
téléspectateurs me le disait quand vous
restez c'est possible et donc voilà
mais maintenant voilà on s'est tenu par
la main on a dit qu'on arrive tous les
deux des huit on et voilà on va passer à
autre chose mais sur le coup il sait
très bien il n'a pas été cool donc
mauvaise idée donc ça ça vous fait chier
de le voir tous les jours
non parce que ça va aller vous allez
faire des émissions semblent pas où je
vois je vous sais pas non je pense que
c'est bien justement il faudrait
forcément une bonne idée alors enora
bonne idée je suis étonné oui parce que
moi je me fous de l'humain ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le travail avec le
halal par l'étonnant mais elle aussi son
point de vue mais moi je trouve que ça
va être génial pour moi j'ai pu voir
m'embrouiller justement sur la télé
réalité avec le spécialiste de
latéralité on est on n'aime pas du tout
la même chose je pense qu'on va être
d'accord sur à peu près rien du tout
donc embellie pour l'émission je trouve
et puis pour lui c'est bien qu'il fasse
autre chose il était complètement fermée
à nrj12 en faisant des choses très
médiocres là il a une nouvelle vie
devant lui c'est top jean-luc mauvaise
idée mathieu de l'envoi dans touche pas
aux pales un point très honnête il des
restes en plateau est cité en face de
moi je redis bonne idée là il est sorti
donc des idées je n'ai rien à [ __ ]
parce que globalement je crois je m'en
fous un peu
c'est ma cinquième
rentrée avec touche pas à mon poste et
j'ai appris avec le temps à ne pas
m'attacher aux nouveaux ouais je sais
pas c'est pas que j'aime pas
complètement faux est très vite bonne
idée au bas mot puisque les bonnes idées
chez moins intéressant que les mauvaises
idées
évidemment évidemment pas où je pense
que ça va être une délivrance comme vous
le disiez pour lui tout a l'air donc
c'est une très bonne idée le centre aéré
je pense qu'il en avait marre
et puis a toujours dit je sais faire
autre chose donc bonne idée on a envie
de voir ce que ça donne mater leurs mots
sur les choses
moi je me suis super bonne idée parce
qu'on va s'apercevoir que c'est pas
uniquement un intervieweur aka goal de
la télé réalité
j'étais un producteur talentueux et en
plus un journaliste de la presse écrite
je me souviens de ses chroniques dans
paris match la télé qui était très bonne
rien donc on va on va apprendre de lui
alors gilles vous mauvaise idée très
mauvaise idée
c'est une sorte de sous l'habile a donc
ils vont arrêter connais ton en dessous
la villa oui il va être extrêmement
langue de bois
ouais j'ai un mauvais débatteurs bon
animateur
j'y crois pas une seconde c'est pas vrai
il a toujours assumé le second degré
cyan est-ce qu'il a présentées et
surtout de mettre un terrain partout
comme d'hab il a été l'âge il était
super potable baissera pas et je pense
qu'il a moins envie de pécho de matthieu
delormeau et d'habitat il est pas langue
de bois du tout nature histoire alors
avant il y les palombes den broeck
mauvaise idée pour moi je trouve que
c'est une mauvaise idée parce que je
pense ce garçon manque de recul et
second degré justement la première fois
qu'il est venu sur ce plateau
c'est à l'époque de france 4 il a fondu
en larmes quand il aura la charge et moi
je trouve que le mec qu'a pas ça prouve
que c'est loin d'être humain eh bah oui
mais justement lui un terrible accident
- être humain donc voila quand même
alors oui et moi je trouve ça assez
dommage et je suis sûr effectivement qui
ne qui ne crachera pas dans la soupe
il va y va continuer à rester planté sur
ses à nous dire que tellement vrai c'est
vrai par exemple et que rien que ça déjà
travaillé les abeilles
ça fait sept ans qui me vend même plus
de sept ans que tu me vends des
programmes de merde qui me pourrissent
la vie je veux dire donc me retrouver
avec lui là franchement excusez moi mais
ça me colle alors quand
angela blé pas dit vous moi rien que
qu'il existe ce débat sur mathieu je me
dis qu'il a tout gagné et je suis pour
puisque d'abord je pense que c'est un
grand professionnel après j'étais pas je
vais pas ce qu'il faisait sur sur les
anges je dois dire je le vis maintenant
je pense que tout le monde a droit à
faire d autre chose a changé
il a un regard sur la télé j'ai produit
en programmes dans lesquels il était
chroniqueur il est excellent je trouve
qu'il a sa place et rien que parce que
vous aimez pas j'adore voilà donc à rien
que parce qu'on fait ces débats là je
trouve qu'il a vraiment sa place
voilà parce qu'on fait le débat vous
trouvez qu'il a sa place allez bon va
l'accueillir tout de suite allé matthieu
delormeau des faits
alors
mathieu progrès n'est qu'à son mojo ni
mon badge battu reprenait récapitule à
part le prix des matières premières est
question que nous aurons à faire du
verso ou fermé n'a pas mathieu
honnêtement way rav-ner sérieux quand
vous êtes hyper v lire mais non mais
t'as entendu des trucs non mais juste
pour commencer avec christophe plus dans
trois secondes je veux quand tu veux
dire que tu es demanderait c'est vrai
parce que je produis et donc je sais ce
que je produis je mens pas chez pas
langue de bois maintenant si on avait
voulu attends je termine si tu avais
voulu en septembre plutôt que juste
poser tes fesses et commentés venir une
seule fois assister un tournage pour
voir que c'est vrai qu'à assister
journaliste tu regardes les faits si
c'est vrai c'est vrai si c'est pas vrai
tu dénonces mais en l'occurrence même la
soirée d'annoncé du monde
mais pour revenir juste une fois vérifié
je viens sur le terrain c'était six mois
mathieu quand je vais sur journée
s'avérer viable et sa voix tu dis tu
fais sur un tournage a priori parce que
j'aime ou le film ou l'émission lac
excuse-moi d'entretien dont une où il ya
à mes yeux tu produis de la merde qu'est
ce que tu lui mets et c'est de la merde
mais elle vient vérifier ses fans le
maire truqué c'est bien attendez
attendez attendez c'est la merde
attendait et isabelle morini-bosc que
c'est de la merde je sais c'est pas de
ma vie c'est de la mer salée premier
mensuel porte une accusation exactly
gènes hla pouvait pas l'approuver faut
que tu ailles est en faillite en dieu
qu'est prouve-le ya pas eu de réussite
en allemagne a parlé tout n'est jamais
venu sur l'étude et manu pas mal
d'articles qui l'ont pas été pour celui
mais je m'en fous tellement vrai je peux
vous dire c'est c'est généralement frais
après refonte mercer je n'ai jamais payé
je le jure sur ma tête je me sens mes
neveux je n'ai jamais payé je te dit
blake eu lieu hier et celle au centre je
n'ai jamais truqués quelque chose viril
aller quelqu'un va venir vérifier bien
en l'occurrence c'est très facile de
critiquer quand y en a un à qui on
demande de bouger son cul pour venir sur
un tournage et de vérifier s'il ya plus
personne
une information c'est pas une rumeur qui
devient il un fossé on vérifie cette
viande info ça arrive c'est le navire
l'inspecteur barnaby oui
voilà
oui vous voulez dire quelque chose pour
moi je trouve que c'est très réducteur
ce que tu dis christophe parce que
tellement vrai le résumé a de la merde
comme ça moi je suis désolé je me
souviens de documents j'adore il ya que
mathieu a produit avec adriana karembeu
i way où elle revenait dans sa ville
d'origine et de qualité et je pense
qu'ils à faire des documentaires de
qualité sur nrj12 aussi d'ailleurs ce
qu'on voudra mais on sait accueillir les
nouveaux
un dernier mot après je vous dis juste
un truc je le dis chaque année ne me
fait jamais ça commence à jamais préfère
rouler sous les genres ça genre ça mais
pas ça oui après non j'ai pas langue de
bois et merci évidemment pour tout ce
qu'on dit des mots gentils et quant à
erika jeu mais j'hallucine de ma vie on
ne s'est croisé deux fois je n'ai jamais
animé une émission avec toi tu sais même
pas comment les gens on peut dire que tu
es mal accueillie je n'ai jamais fini
les 5 twh été croisé deux fois dans ma
vie je ne t'ai jamais vu une fois nrj 12
alors que tu es une antipathie c'est
possible mais que tu penses que tu viens
de dire si l on s'est croisé deux fois
dans nos vies on a parlé sur le clip là
tu sais que je t'ai dit écoute comment
ça se fait que à ce point tu mets paru
si désagréable et j'attends et je tenais
les exemples je t'ai dit tu sais qu'il
voulait pas l'appeler ce soir mathieu
chez moi mais là on pointe le problème
dès qu'on dit quelque chose sur vous
trois heures de justification
papa
vous avez toujours cette rentrée si un
gars au dracula le gars vous n'acceptez
pas vous n'acceptez pas le débat va voir
si tu les tiens on n'acceptait pas le
débat excepté pas le débat ouais je sais
la voix soit cette rentrée est
incroyable
ce dracula masse le gard attendez
attendez attendez se fait défoncer par
tout moyen à laurie qui règlent leurs
confrères sans merci les officiers quand
même d'être bien voilà je vais fermer ma
gueule je pense que c'est pas agréable
moi je lui dis déjà chapeau de ré de
garder ton sang froid parce que moi
j'aurais mis déjà 3 par aline dans le
buffet de tout le monde
ou alors émis 3 praline parce que je
paye grille était garé en double file
avec les patins faut pas non plus car
ces deux là on a dépassé car
professionnel gilles me sens donc moi je
te dis bienvenue et j'adorerais qu on
s'embrouille ensemble toute l'année
alors aimé réussir et mathieu mathieu tu
sais je me sens j'ai habité à gatineau
et le gars passe mal le dîner servir la
d'emballement j'arrive l'a fait c'est
que vous êtes aperçu
à
au bac je vois que vous êtes peut-être
content d'être venu dans l'équipe kolles
a non mais en fait c'est presque un
nettement merci 30 secondes merci mille
fois de m'avoir de m'avoir appelé et
c'est dire si ce n'était un merci de
votre accueil